the russian buildup now extends to
belarus where thousands of troops are
planning snap exercises on ukraine's
northern border
in moscow president vladimir putin
accused the u.s of trying to draw russia
into armed conflict warning american
attempts at diplomacy outlined in a
letter last week were badly off course
fundamental russian concerns were
ignored he said
putin's demands include rolling back the
size of nato and banning ukraine from
joining the alliance the west isn't
budging on either point
in kiev where the british prime minister
paid a visit there are signs the
ukrainian government now views the
russian threat with the same alarm as
the west this wouldn't be a war between
ukraine and russia warned ukrainian
president zelinski this would be a
full-scale war in europe
a further
russian
invasion
of ukraine would be a political disaster
a humanitarian disaster ukraine the uk
and poland are now preparing to form
their own trilateral alliance at nato
headquarters canada's defense minister
echoed the western view that what
happens next is up to putin russia has
an important
choice to make
it can choose to negotiate with a view
to de-escalation
or it can face
harsh economic sanctions despite all
those worrying signs putin did leave the
door open to more dialogue suggesting a
deal may be reached eventually the u.s
is still waiting on a formal russian
response to its written proposals so far
there's no sign there will be enough
there to end the tense stare down over
ukraine
jackson prosko global news washington